la migración vuelve al centro del debate
político en eeuu un grupo de
republicanos fue hasta el paso en el
estado de texas para recorrer las
instalaciones de procesamiento de
emigrantes el líder de la minoría de la
cámara de representantes- culpó a la
nueva administración de joe biden del
sufrimiento de los migrantes y denunció
riesgos sanitarios para los
estadounidenses esa crisis es creada por
las políticas presidenciales de esta
nueva administración
no hay otra forma de llamarlo que una
crisis fronteriza de beijing el aumento
de la llegada de migrantes a la frontera
entre méxico y eeuu se produce luego de
que bailen revirtiera algunas de las
políticas restrictivas del ex presidente
de donald trump muchos de ellos creen
que las cosas podrían ser más simples
ahora con el demócrata en la casa blanca
quien espera regularizar a cerca de 11
millones de inmigrantes indocumentados
que viven en estados unidos pero el
camino para lograr el llamado sueño
americano es uno lleno de obstáculos hay
que venir rodeando cada entrada cada
pueblito que ven y rodeando por el monte
a veces si no pega con migración pega
con los malandros
que hay bienes en eeuu no puede andar
sin ropa y en esta situación preocupa la
gran cantidad de menores de edad
viajando solos para el viernes la
oficina de refugiados del departamento
de salud contaba 8 mil 800 de ellos en
custodia donde albergarlos es el nuevo
dolor de cabeza para el nuevo gobierno
la portavoz de la casa blanca aseguró
que actualmente buscan instalaciones
para todos ellos y culpa a la
administración de trump de haber dejado
un sistema migratorio desmantelado